That's my side
Beanie
It's still alive
It's home made me feel
Good
Bye bye bye
I know latia I'm scared bitch okay every
time it happened like this it be like that
and I hope you are still in I hope I swear
to God I hope you are still there that bitch
didn't drop another $3 on his but you
probably had another 20 to 30 40 50%
It was trust me over the weekend that's all
I'm saying that's all I'm saying nobody
wants to listen but you could have took any
amount of money right so
Next timeWin or loss I'm going to show you
like.
That's what I'm going to start doing is just
showing you the little amount of money you
could take and be doing this shit like I
honestly made a funny dollars on an easy
school
With a $150Why you broke.
Not not you specifically but I'm just saying
like
What I need to start doing is taking
screenshots of the position and different
prices of positions then like putting it
together so that you could see
Like I'm going to show you what I mean like
a little example of what I'm saying cuz I
don't think people really just understand it
like
With $150 I just made $100
You know what I'm saying
So now tomorrow I got two shots and making
the same thing and to be honest with you I
always get out early I ain't going to lie to
you when my positions do go your boy lose
like three to four hundred dollars cuz I'm
scared bitch but I'm also a greedy bitch it
is I don't know
When I'm being a greedy bitchI get punished
when I'm being a scary bitch.
I make $100 off of 150 and I bragging about
the money that I left on the table and so a
good day to me is
Me complaining about how much I left on the
table cuz we still up
I can't take a really just
understanding$150.
In people DetroitHell no I'm telling people
what I'm doing that's it I'm just showing
what I'm doing so.
That also means you need to know I'm not
profitable for the Year bro
Not at all always blow my shit on some dumb
shit
In fact
Let's go do the numbersCuz I'm also a colder
too so. Today.
OrMain.
Focus in the coding world not main focus in
the golden World cuz I got an agent swarm
that works for me but
One thing that I'll get them to work on is
figuring out my statisticsHow accurate.
IsThe trade in robot look.
How hard is that for me to implement right
now is not actually hard for me to implement
me implementing something like that is that
looks like good news wait I'm sorry I got a
message that just came in about the
inflation just came in about inflation okay
I need to go check it out
Need somethingPeriod.
All right soOnly remember when I was working
with really bad shit.
Figment
I'm going to happen
2:30 you still in itAnd it hold that 4:40.
Where I get outMoney has been made you been
great.
But you know let your winners ride y'all
better than me
Wish I was with youI hope to see everybody
at the profit party for today.
Chicken DriveTractor.
So what that show you is that if you had$50.
Then you would have20 bucks. So you could
have made 20 bucks off $50.
If you had
So much
But either way
My story is the account is at 300 bucks I'm
taking 50 out
So we're at 250And we'll be back tomorrow to
do the same shit.